Hey how's it going it's Samuel Leeds
here we're here at the country match I
just wanted to give a video to you guys
because it's coming very close to the
deal finding extravaganza and r0 program
I just want to say I've had a lot of
people come to me and say that they want
to be part of that program and there's
becoming to move three four five
thousand pounds to try and attempt and I
have told them no we're sold out the
first thing we're going to be covering
is how to source properties on deal
finding extravaganza
now people pay us regularly 2,000 pounds
for us to find a property for them
you're going to learn that skill or
whether you want to find properties for
yourself or if you want to pass them on
you will have that scale after deal
finding extravaganza it's a fabulous day
and I'm really excited about it we then
have two days of zero training zero the
zero program is just absolutely
incredible
we've had people attend this program
find Lease Option agreements over the
two days and either keep them and have a
house for free or pass them on for four
five thousand pound fees so that is just
incredible so the second thing you learn
is how to find and secure lease option
agreement no money down deals and then
the third thing that we're going to be
going through is how to be a deal
sorcerer how to package deals up and
pass them on for a fee you're going to
have so much opportunity on that three
days so much learning so much practice
you know what I mean the stuff that
you're going to be getting from the
three days the investment that you paid
I expect you to get that back within
weeks and then you'll have a lifelong
skill they'll be able to replace your
income help you become financially
independent and you will be a property
expert where people were paying you soon
to teach them how to do these skills
there's going to be so much opportunity
laid out and this is going to be a
fabulous year
god bless your Sisu I'm actually shaking
I'm so excited
[Music]